oh I might cry a bit so today we're
gonna be talking about trends from the
90s we were born in the 90s so we're
gonna back baby
I feel like platform shoes were kind of
a thing there's a lot of like silky kind
of shirts happening which is a choice
backstreet's back Wow best we're a big
deal
do you remember vests so many vests it's
my last oh this is a gift with doughnuts
why did you put a gift in front of me is
this a 90s trend or trying to think if I
have anything for the 90s that I so like
a present you didn't see this would
happen present so a Backstreet Boy am I
supposed to open this you not saying
anything to me okay there's also just
reminds me of our birthdays and how
often we just get joint presents so it's
weird to just have two gifts yeah
exactly
it's a box yeah I really like the
wrapping paper and I really hope it's
nineties clothes all right
I'm not ready I'm not ready am I ready
are you okay
okay should we go one at a time oh my
god Baby Alive it is a baby alive Wow
I like didn't play with dolls very much
but when I was a child I think it was
called like baby born I don't know if
it's the same brand
there was a commercial and it was like
baby born baby born and you could feed
the baby as it appears you can do with
this baby growing up oh my gosh these
are so dangerous that's why we were
never allowed to have them because they
were so dangerous I can still remember
the commercial remember he's like sky
dancers and like they were like in the
sky
exactly it wow it's been so long since
I've like opened a toy that I like
barely even know how to do I had like a
couple Barbies but not that many but I
did really want to feed the little baby
because it you could feed it and it
likes it got sucked in I think I really
just liked that mechanism
I liked the mystery behind it at
Blockbuster they had this shelf of
movies that were like kids animated
films and we were always allowed to pick
one off of the shelf each time and we
watched sky dancer so often that our mom
is like okay you can pick any movie but
sky dancer so much are these actually
gonna fly like already so excited about
it
we have these instructions
Valerie okay I'm supposed to add water
to the fill line of my dolls blender
bowl I'm guessing that's what this is
wow it's like science
what are we feeling today we can have
doll food it looks like broccoli perhaps
on the outside or doll food that looks
like a pear what are you feeling pear
yeah I think pear goes better with water
too
okay what are they gonna do or think
okay okay this is everything I thought
they would be I struggle with this as an
adult I definitely would have struggled
with this Wow I feel like there's just
one really big clump in the middle they
say you can use a spoon mouth it's like
you shut up like I'm excuse me Valerie
I'm sorry yeah you traitors let's
prepare you for eating there's
definitely nothing about this that is an
offer all right we're gonna give you
some of our viscous pear slime I don't
know it's just like I understand that
like her mouth is just a hole into which
I'm dumping this in but there's
something I'm like about seeing it in
the spoon and then watching it disappear
that's that's really fun come on taste
it it does not taste good okay I want to
see how far they go how far they fly can
we take them outside outside okay ready
you gotta get it up okay here I go three
two one three two
what go
break off guitar it was let's check out
what your diaper situation is excuse me
I'm sorry I'm doing this is because you
have a bubble all right let's see what's
happening in here
oh my god Wow you opened the diaper and
there's weird green that was you know
what worth it very fun I would
definitely do it again my expectations
for what I wanted as a kid were
definitely met I've always wanted the
sky pubes are so badly and we were just
never allowed to have them and now this
is what getting to be an adult is all
about see mom look how much fun we could
have had could have been great
[Music]
you
[Music]